things are getting tense and tempers are
flaring as the migrant crisis
intensifies here in the u.s new video
capturing border patrol agents
confronting the border patrol chief over
president biden's immigration policies
bill malugin is in la jolla texas with
all the details for us good to see you
bill
hey jackie good afternoon to you so that
video happened yesterday this was when
dhs secretary alejandra mayorkas was
visiting border patrol agents in laredo
texas and during that meeting border
patrol agents in laredo got into a
heated back and forth with their boss
u.s border patrol chief raul ortiz they
let them know they're not happy with
what's going on and a border patrol
source leaked me that video take a look
i've been doing this job as long as
y'all that's the problem what's that
that's a problem
for people the triumph is for good men
to do nothing i can't hear you for evil
the triumph is for good men to do
nothing that's exactly what's happening
here good men are doing nothing you're
allowing illegal drugs
you are doing something
meanwhile earlier this morning take a
look at this video we shot in the early
morning hours groups of family units
arriving where we are here in la jolla
texas about a hundred in total while we
were out here and these were very chilly
temperatures keep in mind it's late
january out here it gets very cold in
the middle of the night but still these
migrants make the journey to cross the
rio grande and enter texas illegally
in those chilly nighttime temperatures
and out here last night also was
oklahoma republican senator james
lankford he was getting a tour of the
area by the border patrol union so we
could get a first-hand look at what's
going on out here he says border patrol
agents just aren't allowed to do their
jobs right now take a listen
whether it's single adults that are
coming in whether it's family groups
coming in they're coming across checking
in and then border patrol agents and
other individuals that are here to be
able to enforce the laws of the country
are actually just managing and being
more like hotel check-in staff and being
instructed by the administration here's
how to process people and release them
rather than to actually try to actually
carry out the law
and throughout this border crisis we
have been reporting that these migrants
have been showing up at the border from
literally all around the world more than
120 countries and i've just learned from
a dhs source that here in the rio grande
valley on thursday five men from syria
were arrested by border patrol agents
after they crossed illegally into
hidalgo texas about 20 minutes away from
where we are right now we'll send it
back to you bill malujin thank you so
much for that